I'm Jennifer Kulina-Lanese,...
...I'm a field responder for the Humane Society of the United States,...
...from Monmouth County, New Jersey, taking care of some of the victims of Hurricane Sandy.
This is Moxie.
Her family was displaced; they were actually,...
Hi Moxie!
They actually had to be rescued.
It's essential that we have pet-friendly shelters.
We know and we've learned from Katrina...
...that folks are not going to leave and abandon their animals.
There is over 25 dogs, almost 20 cats, three birds and a rabbit.
They are here for the long term.
However long it takes, HSUS is committed to providing support.
We don't see this as a short-term cleanup.
We don't know when power is gonna be back on.
We know for sure it's gonna be weeks, maybe even months.
It's heartbreaking and uplifting at the same time.
You see everybody,...
...they've lost everything, but they still have their pets,...
...and I know that gives them a lot of comfort.
But it's heart-wrenching.
We're just happy that we're able to assist.